in this video we are going to talk about
microcephaly
microcephaly is a neurodevelopmental
disorder where the size and the
circumference of the head of a child is
significantly smaller in comparison to a
children of same age and same sex there
could be microcephaly where the
brain is like smaller and the overall
head circumference is three standard
deviation apart
compared to a
normal baby and there are cases of
severe microcephaly in this video we are
going to talk about the clinical
presentation of microcephaly subtypes of
microcephaly the causes behind
microcephaly both environmental and the
genetic causes and lastly we are going
to focus on the latest research on
microcephaly
so
microcephaly is associated with many
symptoms like backward sloping forehead
small head size dwarfism overall short
stretcher
increased risk of seizures delay in
speech and movement facial distortion
and many other symptoms
now microcephaly can be divided into two
categories
one is primary micro microcephaly where
the defects are observed during the
development of the fetus inside the
mother's womb
and in case of secondary microcephaly
the symptoms occur postnatally that
means after the birth
and it occurs in a progressive fashion
it leads to a progressive degeneration
and reduction in the head size
now when it comes to the cause of
microcephaly there could be genetic as
well as environmental factors involved
in microcephaly progression now let us
talk about the genetic factors first and
then we talk about the environmental
factors
so high throughput sequencing data has
characterized several mutations which
are associated with microcephaly
and many of these mutations
abrogate different cell
cellular pathways
25 genetic loci has been associated with
primary microcephaly
and all of these loci's are known as
mcph1 mcph2 till mcph25
and the genes that are present in this
loci they are involved in cell division
centriole biogenesis cilia biogenesis
dna damage response all of these kind of
biological processes
taken together all of them
are involved in kinetics of cell
division and cell growth question is how
these processes are related to
microcephaly and how they are underlying
cause
so let's explore that part
the smaller brain size of a microcephaly
patient arises due to abrogation of
cellular and molecular architecture
while neurogenesis is happening
neurogenesis is a process when neurons
are born in the cell from the stem cells
so this is a cross section of a
microcephaly patient
and overall we can understand that
aspects of neurogenesis is dysregulated
so that's why we have to understand
neurogenesis in bit more details so
these green cells are radial glial stem
cells which kind of divides among each
other and they give rise to uh more
radial glial cells and this is called
symmetric division
also they can give rise to newborn
neurons
so first they can divide in a symmetric
fashion giving rise to two radial glia
alternatively there are also possibility
that they can divide asymmetrically and
give rise to a neuron and radial clear
so generally in brain what happens is
these stem cells first
directly doesn't produce neurons
they first increase their numbers
and divide in a proliferative fashion so
they divide initially symmetrically and
this process is known as transit
amplification
that means they increase the number of
stem cells
once there is a certain threshold is
reached then these stem cells start
differentiating into the neurons
in microcephaly this normal procedure is
abrogated
so what happens in microcephaly is
the neurons are produced prematurely the
transit amplification process is not
really happening or defective
so let me tell you in a layman's term
let's say you have a bunch of cash
so in order to like thrive you should
first invest that cash grow that money
and then start spending that money right
then you would not run out of money very
soon
brain does the same
brain increases the number of stem cells
and then leverage themselves to produce
neurons
in contrast microcephaly patients shows
that
instantly all the stem cell pool is
differentiating into neurons instead of
amplifying themselves that's that means
the stem cell pool is exhausted quickly
as if you are spending without
amplifying your money or investing into
some places so soon very soon you would
be running out of money and that's what
happens in the brain as well brain runs
out of stem cell which can give rise to
neurons so initially they start
producing neuron very quickly but in the
long term it's harmful for them because
they run out of cells that can produce
neuron they end up getting less neurons
and that's why in microcephaly patient
we can see
there is a
reduction in cortical thickness overall
we can understand for a cell division to
occur there are several aspects
molecular and cellular aspects are
important
so one of that aspect is centriole
biogenesis and function of the centriole
and that is super important in context
of cell division since these stem cells
are highly dividing for them as well
centriolar regulation is really really
important and majority of the
microcephaly associated genes are
involved in cell cycle related processes
such as centriole biogenesis mitotic
spindle organization cell cycle
checkpoint let us look at this part in
bit more details
so centriole biogenesis is a complicated
process it involves cellular and
molecular players so first of all q14
map 11 cnpe aspm several proteins are
associated with the microtubular
dynamics and spindle assembly and all of
these proteins that i have mentioned
right now are actually associated with
microcephaly and in patients of
microcephaly these genes are actually
mutated
one important regulator of
pericentriolar matrix is cdk5 rap2 and
that is found to be mutated in mcph
patients
other regulators such as wdr 62 63 sep
15 152 and 7 192 are all protein
scaffolds
in centriolar biogenesis pathway that
means if there is a mutation in these
genes there could be abrogation in the
centriolar biogenesis process and that
had led to
conditions like microcephaly
there are other proteins such as cnpgs
sep 135 sep 100 these are all factors
that help in centriole elongation so
various aspect of centriole is super
important because any of these aspects
are abrogated it leads to or increase
the risk of developing microcephaly
now let's move on to understand how
researchers know so much about
microcephaly so they knew about
microcephaly or the cellular processes
or mechanisms that underlies
microcephaly is based on creating mouse
mutations into those same genes
or microcephaly risk genes
and then they analyze the
newborn pups
but
question is even if scientists can ask
what aspect of neural development has
gone wrong these are kind of mice models
and they are really far from human many
aspects of microcephaly are actually
shown to be not recapitulated in mouse
model of microcephaly that's why
scientists required a human-based model
to understand the mechanisms underlying
microcephaly and that revolution comes
in 2013 when dr madeleine lancaster of
mercy lab cambridge has developed a
protocol known as cerebral organoids
they are also known as mini brains here
using
stem cells or
induced pluripotent stem cells
she can you generate a mini brain like
structure in a bioreactor
and these
small organoids or mini brains are kind
of similar to the cellular and molecular
organization of an adult human brain or
a developing human brain
but there are certain differences
between them as well but the basics are
pretty similar
growing cerebral organoids from
microcephaly patients have
revolutionized under revolutionized the
understanding of this particular disease
so theoretically you can ideally take
skin cells from a microcephaly patient
and from a normal baby and you can make
induced pluripotent stem cell out of
that from that we can use organoid
protocol to understand various aspects
of the brain development and ask the
question what has gone wrong in case of
microcephaly patients
so these are really important question
so a researcher can ask what aspects of
neural development has gone wrong he can
also ask what are the cellular and
molecular mechanism behind it an
organoid plays a crucial role in terms
of understanding these scientific
questions one of the finding that they
had
is there is a reduced cortical thickness
that is kind of recapitulated in these
organoids the organoids also look fairly
small
anyway when
these researchers
knocked down cdk5 rap2 which i have
earlier mentioned is a key player in
centriolar organization or
pericentricular matrix organization
that leads to severe defects they have
also collected
skin samples from
patients which has a mutation in this
gene
and then they build organoid out of it
what they found out was really striking
they found out that in this mutant
background there is a premature
differentiation which is going on
that means
the neurons the the neurons are born or
differentiated really early and stem
cell pool amplification is not really
happening and that is one of the key
mechanism
which can explain why the brain size is
smaller
and that's how organoid technology
allowed researcher to understand what
really goes wrong in a microcephaly
brain
now you might be remembering 2015
because in this year there was a
outbreak of zika virus in brazil
and in the same year there are several
incidents of babies
which are
having like very small brain
circumference a characteristic feature
of microcephaly
question is how zika virus infection is
associated with microcephaly researchers
has found out that zika virus affect
these radial glial stem cells and many
of the time they kill their stem cells
and that's why
too many uh neurons cannot be produced
in these brains and that's how brain
development is severely screwed up
not only zika virus there are other
environmental risk factors such as
rubella toxoplasma cytomegalovirus all
of that can increase the risk of
developing microcephaly if a pregnant
woman is infected by these viruses
other than these viral factors there
could be alcohol
medications toxic chemical exposure all
of these can increase the risk of
microcephaly development
now let me tell you a cool hypothesis
about the theory of evolution
microcephaly actually brings out an
important aspect behind it
people thought that all these
microcephaly associated genes are
positively selected during the course of
evolution when we are developing from a
hominin ancestor and becoming homo
sapiens in this process somewhere these
genes are positively selected and these
genes might have really helped our brain
to grow in size and mature
and that kind of also correlates with
the brain size
and what scientists thinks is really
cool but experimental evidences are
lacking they think
these microcephaly patients actually
recapitulate the hominin ancestor brain
morphology that means it's an example of
atovism or a reversing of a particular
trait during the course of evolution
since these microcephaly associated
genes are crucially important for
the overall brain size or overall
neurogenesis
that's why scientists speculate that
possibly this mutation has led to a
similar morphology like a hominin
ancestor which is quite different from
us
this is pretty cool isn't it let me know
in the comment
now
even if we understand some aspects of
microcephaly the risk factors etc there
is no treatment for microcephaly life
expectancy of that baby with
microcephaly is really low also there
are a lot of intellectual disabilities
sometimes there are motor defects and
many other aspects
so in this video we looked at what is
microcephaly what are the clinical
features of microcephaly what are the
types of microcephaly causes of
microcephaly a quick evolutionary aspect
or insight into microcephaly and the
activity
hypothesis we have explored lastly we
talked about there is no treatment of
microcephaly exists so far
so i hope this was useful if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and
you can get a lot of flashcards notes in
my facebook page check out my facebook
page link is in the description don't
forget to like share and subscribe
support me on patreon you can follow me
on academy using my code a p10 you can
get a 10 discount on my courses thank
you see you next video